yesterday FBI director James Comey got a
letter from President Trump informing
him that his services were no longer
needed yeah after hearing this Melania
Trump said I would kill for one of those
letters she should start investigating
today President Trump promised to bring
back the spirit and prestige of the FBI
that's what he said yeah Trump said when
I'm arrested I want to be arrested by
the very best today Russian president
they asked Vladimir Putin today Russian
President Vladimir Putin said that he
had nothing to do with the firing of FBI
director James Comey yeah Putin said how
could I he's still alive isn't he oh
it's a pro Putin crowd suddenly lady
tell when I came out and they all had
fur hats on its come out that in the
days before the Comey firing Donald
Trump would often scream at cable
television scream at cable television
yeah he'd usually yell you're not the
cake boss on the cake pot let's check
what takes fair out here
analysts are saying that last night's
events could be the beginning of the end
for Donald Trump oh wait no wait wait
I'm I'm sorry this joke is from a
monologue I did last year
I think I did that 20 times last year
after news of the Comey firing broke out
this is true you're gonna think I made
this up but this is true after news of
the Comey firing broke last night press
secretary Sean Spicer avoided reporters
by hiding behind a bush outside the
White House yeah hiding behind a bush
that's true yeah
today Bill Clinton said oh yeah I
remember that Bush
you
you